the loss is unbearable for 13-year-old
Sandra her mother and younger sister
were among the dozens of people who died
when a fire T through a wedding
celebration in the northern Iraqi town
of
hamdia how can I live without them my
mother was only 37 and my sister was not
even 5 years old the lack of a fire
extinguisher has destroyed my life some
people are still unaccounted for after
two his death
disaster my 17-year-old daughter has
disappeared I've searched everywhere all
the hospitals I want to know where she
is even if she's dead tents where
friends and family come to offer
condolences have become a common site on
almost every street in
hamdia civil defense officials say
fireworks sparked the Blaze and that an
investigation is underway into the
building's compliance with safe
standards families blame the owner of
the hall and accuse local authorities of
negligence at the cemetery buddies keep
[Music]
arriving every day we bury loved ones
and others are in a serious condition in
hospital many people here are speechless
we are helpless only God hears
us saying a pray ERS here may give solos
for the victim's families who are
burdened by grief and Agony officials
have promised them anyone found
responsible for this tragedy will be
held accountable but the families also
want negligence to be
criminalized the Prime Minister has
offered his condolences and pledged its
support for the victims families but for
the people of hamdia the distress is
overwhelming
we cannot accept the prime minister's
condolences until he guarantees that
Justice will be
served a trauma Beyond human
endurance how will they ever heal some
here wonder and how will the younger
generation COPE in the years to
come mm Abdul Al jaaz in hamdia Northern
Iraq
Libya's public
prosecut make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer